vendre des médicaments sans ordonnance
au sein de ses magasins une volonté de
l'enseigné leclerc depuis le début des
années 80 à cette époque le fondateur
edouard leclerc s'attaque au monopole
des pharmaciens si les jeunes sont un
chien veulent se joindre à moi ils
peuvent être assurés que je me battrai
pour eux n'en faites pas trop à la fois
la hausse est jamais trop on doit
toujours vivre dix ans avant les autres
si vous voulez gagner en partenariat
avec certains pharmaciens leclerc
commence par s'installer directement
dans des officines ici à montaigu en
vendée pour y vendre sous sa marque des
produits dermo-cosmétiques 20% moins
cher qu'ailleurs
depuis cet après midi dans cette
officine on casse les prix de tous les
produits vendus en pharmacie sauf pour
l'instant des médicaments des produits
au rabais qui ne plaisent pas du tout
aux syndicats des pharmaciens vendée
cela montre à l'évidence je leur dis et
je le répète que monsieur leclerc veut
s'introduire dans le marché du
médicament et dans la distribution du
médicament
trois ans plus tard en 1987 le conseil
de la concurrence donne pourtant raison
à leclerc il prononce même des sanctions
contre les laboratoires qui sur pression
des pharmaciens refusait de livrer les
grandes surfaces la fin d'un monopole
dont se réjouissent elles fils leclerc
et là je crois que le conseil de la
concurrence a été très courageux
vraiment cette décision marque une ère
nouvelle dans l'histoire de la
concurrence les espaces parapharmacie se
développe alors au sein des magasins
leclerc
mais les pharmaciens n'ont pas dit leur
dernier mot en 1990 il saisisse la cour
d'appel de paris qui interdira
finalement la vente en grandes surfaces
de certains produits tels que l'alcool à
70 degrés ou l'arnica considérés comme
des médicaments
seuls les pharmaciens étaient habilitées
à les vendre ou ben dossier des
pharmaciens seulement attention
on va pas verser des salaires de 17
mille francs à des pharmaciens à des
gens qui ont fait 7 ans d'études pour se
tourner les pouces et n'être que des
épiciers et c'est évident qu'on va faire
un pas supplémentaire qu'on va essayer
de monter des officines dans les grandes
surfaces
l'intention est donné et aujourd'hui
encore michel edouard leclerc milite
pour la vente de médicaments sans
ordonnance à prix réduits au sein des
parapharmacies c'est un besoin énorme
que le besoin de santé en france
ce que je propose c'est pas la
révolution c'est que les pharmaciens
dans l'east dans les parapharmacies
leclerc puisse les vendre moins cher
le 4 avril 2019 l'autorité de la
concurrence préconise est d'élargir la
vente des médicaments sans ordonnance
aux parapharmacie et à la grande
distribution
le gouvernement travaille sur la
question la femme peut être de 40 ans de
bataille pour leclerc
[Musique]